Wow oh wow aesthetically so much more
pleasing no hi my name is first tell me
if you don't know now you know your life
is different now
have you been following the Winter
Olympics there a time one of my new /
all-time favourite Winter Olympic
athletes is Adam Ripa he is a male
figure skater if you haven't heard of
him what's she doing he's a male figure
skater from the United States he's
actually fantastic one of the first
openly gay male figure skaters and I'm
just obsessed with him he is outspoken
in the best way possible glamorous in
the most elegant way possible talented
in the most you can't deny that way
possible
fantastic so I'm on brain the way to
like pay homage just someone that I
think is fantastic is to try to show you
recreate their Olympic look that's right
today we are becoming based on solely
the things that I have in my house right
now
it's basically Willie Keaney but like
will it this is the outfit that I will
be trying to recreate based on the
things that I have in my house today
so let's do it so the lower hemisphere
is relatively easy I have some black
leggings and then some black shoes but
the northern hemisphere is where we have
to get creative he's wearing basically a
skin-tight white bodysuit each type of
thing with some decals on it or warning
this video will be extremely relatable
because you won't have all the items in
your house that I have on hand in my
house for instance to recreate this kind
of white bedazzled bodysuit I am using a
lab coat that I had in my closet this is
from Amy hurt a nice first this might
get weird y'all tour and then I have a
bunch of fabric paint that I'm gonna use
to try to recreate the smoggy snowstorm
that's happening on atom refunds upper
half let's do it this obviously is way
longer than the shirt he's wearing I'm
gonna cut it turns out these Party City
lab coats
don't cut well that's a fun relaxing
noise why am i stressed cuz I don't want
to disappoint the greatest ice dancer
skater oh my god it's already wrong I
have these weird fabric spray paints oh
that's good sealing at all of the judges
from the other night that had every
punch you're squirting way above that
russian boy permanent fabric spray paint
right oh there we go
it's basically like hairspray that you
get from the 99-cent store whoa
look we're doing art I feel like I work
on the boardwalk and then ripping you
off I am worried that this is going to
be accurate and beautiful my hand is
hurting just from using a spray bottle
this is like a weird workshop test what
do you see you have daddy issues I'm
gonna take a sponge brush and just like
blend this because obviously that's
birth no I don't know I'm just doing
some smears so now the other major color
he's got going on is a light blue BAM
okay ready this might be great it seems
like you want the shirt to look like a
squid and a smurf just consummated their
relationship so far we're nailing it the
other major thing is he's got sparkles
all over mister
you know what I got sparkles let's do
this okay look I just spent way more
time than I'd like to admit hot glowing
beads on to this party city lab coat I
get why sometimes people like making
their own costumes there was something
weirdly therapeutic about this and also
this looks like the Billy Ray Cyrus
version of an atom rippin costume but
that aside it's now time to become you
the best type of filmmaking I can do by
myself out
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I don't know about you guys but I
feel like I nailed this one wanna take
out a rip on for being one of the
greatest athletes of our time and I
apologize him for this cuz you guys like
this video give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to this youtube
channel click the bell notifications to
get notified when I upload videos
because I am consistently inconsistent
here other than that I don't know who
knew Healy's were like awful how does he
do it
I kept going back and forth on making
this video because I was like who wants
to watch this no one actually no one
nothing about this is helpful this is
just me being like how can i upcycle the
stuff in my closet that I don't use and
it's taking up space / also highlight a
human in the Olympic industry that is
really making great strides for society
and his sport so maybe there's not
answer for that yes I look like one of
those styrofoam cups that they serve
coffee and sometimes at bodegas